hello and welcome to this video then
just watch your media have a long
session of blitz games you feel like
you're not doing all that well and then
you are black against haga place be
three for the five billions time okay so
he plays this weird move water let's go
ahead what the beep I can also give back
where do you go now somehow I mean okay
i can play normal moves and be fine but
maybe just this I'm not sure if I want
to play a quickly five here maybe he
plays t5 know
he's just happy with some sort of Becky
French position let's gain some space
where did I spend 40 seconds epic a
sometimes wonder about those things I
felt a plate quickly but it doesn't seem
to be the case yes to do something now
about 90 s III or night XD 3
yeah like that but how do I actually
play em I can gain more space
okay not something that I expected clean
that counterplay does not feel
particularly quick but okay age 4g form
yeah it takes a moment until ahead with
the head until i hit with our five
definitely
yeah I want to plan out h 7 + f5 attack
on on the King side and he's trying to
play on the queenside I want to waste
much time here going to do that anyway
but if I think longer I play the same
move so I just go ahead now maybe he
plays like 22 and castles long it is
possible check
it's not something I expected so you try
to check me here my king some b5 and I
don't know if three is probably falling
I'd like to trade that
you
I still have to be a little bit cautious
there with the king my king is somewhat
and somewhat Airy they have 27 I don't
think you did something extremely
dangerous but you can easily screw it up
t cream shakes the Queen can come to a
six
okay get some peace over
might be some tech tech on c6 here takes
takes knight c6 this this kind of thing
good work
and he's some head on the clock here
that's good
once to swing this over I could be tool
what if I do that actually like
pre-empting this threatening a B and if
he takes the B file is open yeah that
should be good right yeah that looks
good check okay so here I take it and
shake him check
now that looks good at least timewise
should be enough and the position is not
bad yeah it should should be a winning
position check white forfeits on time
okay so I Easter vinia against Hogan
[Music]
yeah the opening result i think was
pretty good this is a strange way of
playing putting the night on e 594 I
think actually that that makes quite
some sense like it takes takes I mean
that should be kind of okay but see for
coming here they feel that it is strange
to just lose so much time with that
piece ya can't hear we would just have a
French position now I'm threatening to
take him so we had to play something
like that yeah that was very logical and
now we have some kind of race Sally's on
the queenside and I'm on the Kings side
and what I think is that it wasn't a
good idea to check me down on each file
that costs really act quite some time o
Knight a5 was very strong but it's so
bad they mediate b5 is hitting he's got
this one also oh okay so I should have
played night f7 year or kf8 actually
yeah yeah and the data actually thought
about briefly if I should go King g78
a jade because the king is really safe
on age 8 but yeah at the end up late
King do seven now things are ok again
[Music]
now yet this one moment here is chatting
and it was quite convincing yeah he is a
really frequent opponent it was game 49
49 and must cause + 21 food 13 losses 34
wins one draw ok thanks for watching